you never know what makes a show
successful if you could identify
the ingredients and separate them
then you'd be a genius but no one nobody
knows it's a combination of factors it's
great actors great writing great
directors
great producers we've been very lucky
disco pigs
i had done the play disco pigs that was
my first ever job and then three years
later they made a movie of the play
and i played that character
and it wasn't the first film i'd done
but it was the first film i did i
suppose that people took any notice of
and i have a lot of affection for that
character because it was the first
role i ever played
professionally i think it's an
exploration of it of a highly
dysfunctional relationship you know
between these kids who are not yet
adults really there's it's their 17th
birthday and
the relationship had been platonic until
then and he obviously wants to make it
something else and
and i think it spins him off into
some sort of a breakdown we never really
pathologized it because we didn't want
to reduce what the character was going
through to that
but uh
yeah he's he's kind of bereft
by the other character runt leaving him
and uh
it sends them into this spiral of kind
of
of of sort of violence and
self-destruction really
[Music]
i'm [ __ ] over mr crabby boys
it's very sad at the ending because he
he acquiesces to his own death because i
think he knows that he will only
set her free
through his own
demise
[Music]
it's very sad and beautiful
and yeah we shot on a beach around here
actually but it's beautifully observed
piece of writing in the theater by ender
walsh and uh
and i think we made a good stab at it as
a film you know
28 days later
in 28 days later i think danny boyle had
seen disco pigs and i think that's why
when i got the the audition or it was
like one of five auditions i i think he
put me through about five auditions for
that i mean i'd been you know
shallow grave and trainspotting were two
definitive films for me growing up i you
know before i ever wanted
contemplated becoming an actor those two
films were
highly significant for me and
you know
danny is you know one of the best
directors in the world so
it was a huge thing for me to get that
role he's got an amazing energy it's
kind of infectious uh how enthusiastic
he is about every aspect of
making a film you know he's totally in
love with uh
the process of filmmaking and um
he never sits down he knows everyone's
name he's an incredibly uh thoughtful
director and the notes that he gives are
they can change your whole performance
you know and he really
pushed me on that film because i hadn't
hadn't done much film acting at that
stage and we shot it in the summer of uh
2001
so we'd go out really really really
early like four in the morning just
pre-dawn and then just as it was the
dawn was breaking
they would ask people to stop walking
and then the art department would run in
and just dress it really really quickly
[Music]
and then cameras all over
all over the place but there were these
domestic cameras with the little
remember the ones with the little tiny
little cartridges it was before hd or
anything like that tv
good old days of tv and uh so everyone
could shoot them and they just had loads
and loads of footage
and we got it like kind of
miraculously we got this footage and i
think maybe they painted out like lights
or stuff but it's all in camera you know
that character reaches this place where
he he goes from this sort of
like
very benign terrified
bike courier to this sort of
vengeful kind of um
you know a man who's not afraid to take
life and and i think it's because he
realizes that this the future
that he has rests with these two women
and he has to protect them in order to
survive
[Music]
it was a uh
it was a
a prosthetic prosthetic head i think
they used like
light cheese for the eyes or something
like that maybe they didn't but i like
to remember that fact it's a brilliant
script by alex garden you know when you
put an ordinary man in this
extraordinary situation
how do you react
that's why i think why people identify
with the movie because it was like a
reimagining of the zombie genre but also
a kind of a
an examination of of what what what what
would one do in that sort of scenario
and he is fight or flight thing
batman trilogy batman begins dark night
dark knight rises
i'd seen chris's movies
um
prior
to batman begins and i was a huge fan
of them you know following
and memento
about 10 of us went up for batman and i
i was aware that i was clearly not the
right material for batman i didn't think
so i did a screen test in the whole suit
and everything and uh
but chris said there might be another
part
so
so we met and we chatted
uh and and
and i and i and i ended up playing
scarecrow in the end yeah
he's here
oh
the batman
he's one of the oldest villains in the
in the series so they gave me some one
of some of the early very early comics
which i read even though it's huge
you know big studio picture big studio
production it's only chris his cameraman
and the first lady who are around when
you're shooting it's a very private
very calm very quiet set there's no
monitors there's no video villages none
of that stuff and
so even though it's a huge movie it
feels like a an independent film and
i've always felt that
the only difference between those films
is the resources you have and it's how
you
utilize the resources so chris is very
confident in delivering scale but also
he concentrates very much on performance
and with that character we wanted to
show the two he's supposed to be this
sort of
a psychiatrist working in an asylum and
he's you know
quite amenable and clever and all of
that
yeah dr crane i can't take it anymore
it's all too much the walls are closing
in blah blah blah a couple of days of
this food it'll be true
what do you want
i want to know how you're going to
convince me to keep my mouth shut about
what you don't know anything and then
he's this this other
sort of uh
you know this i guess he's there he's a
comic book villain
would you like to see my mask
i use it in my experiments
i'm probably not very frightening to
a guy like you
with these crazies you can't stand it
so when did the nut take over the nut
house
you could have fun and you could be a
bit broad and that was fun for me to do
i'd never done anything like that i
didn't expect to be
expect to come back it was wonderful fun
to reprise a character up until that
point i'd never reprise a character
and uh there was a joke on set that he's
just the you know the character that
refuses to die he's still alive
out there
somewhere
you are
phillips driver executive vice president
of
dragon industries who for years has been
living off the blood and sweat
of people less powerful than him
i'm i am one of you maine has no
authority here this is merely a
sentencing hearing no choice is yours
exile
or death
[Applause]
it's exciting
it's old that one scene chris sent me
the script but i deliberately didn't
want to read the script
i just want to read that one scene
because i wanted to see the film and
enjoy the film without having read it so
i didn't read it so i came in and i
didn't know what this was about or what
where what context it had or anything
like that but i just did the scene death
or
exile frame if you think we're going out
onto that ice willingly
you have another thing coming
death that
looks that way very well
death
by exile
i remember trying to keep it secret i it
was so hard trying to keep it secret you
know
uh
people just love a spoiler
everyone kept asking
i think we kept it secret i don't i
can't remember
inception
chris called me up and said this is that
there was a role in there in the script
and and he sent me the script and i read
it this time and uh it was a challenging
read you know it was one of those
scripts you had to read several times to
figure out the sort of vernacular of it
and um
and it was challenging making it because
just trying to figure out where you are
all the time and the structure of the
piece
but chris had been living with that
story i think for about 10 years before
he got to make it
and to make that
sort of a story
on that sort of a
was was incredible and for it to do so
well again as a very very sophisticated
and not easy
blockbuster you know it just shows you
never underestimate your audience you
know because the audience are just so
clever and will go with you
the character
you know has this kind of um
emotional catharsis in the middle of the
film which was
very important
for the story and very important for me
performance-wise and i got to act with
pete possibly you know who would have
been one of my acting heroes and that
sequence and that scene and
if you work with actors of that level
uh
[Music]
it's really and with directors of that
level
you know you you you're expected to to
get there
i know you were disappointed
i couldn't be you
no
no no
i was disappointed
how you get there i don't know
it's
some sort of weird alchemy but it
happens and then we and we got there and
you know it also took we took our time
with it because it needed to have that
emotional wallop to it for everything
else to make sense
so
that was a good day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again with chris you know it's
predominantly in camera he's he's very
reluctant to use cgi unless entirely
essential um so that's why i think his
films are so visceral and so such
such kind of honesty to them and because
most of the stuff you're seeing actually
happened to me
um i'm sorry
who did you say you were brought green
from marketing
that's not true at all isn't
my name is mr charles you remember me
don't you
i'm the head of your security down here
that was my first day on set actually i
remember that was my first day on
saturday remember the water in the glass
tilts like that
you feel that
you've actually been trained for this mr
fisher pay attention to the strangeness
of the weather in order to achieve that
effect that built a whole the whole bar
was on a gimbal that just went
so it wasn't again no cgi so they built
this huge huge set and we came on and
did the scene and then the set just
tilted
as stuff went
crazy but that's the the amount of
planning and
um thought that went into that whole
film to every set every shot every
sequence that's the brilliance of chris
nolan's imagination
you know he
it's kind of staggering that that all
came from his brain you know
[Music]
when it shakes the party
held a great responsibility again with
that film you know i i auditioned for
ken loach like four or five times
they're very rigorous
um
auditions and a lot of
uh improvisations and obviously i knew
about that period of history but not in
depth not to the extent that uh
i subsequently learned about it ken has
got a great relationship with with can
they they
rightfully adore his films and uh
i mean he's he's again
a master of cinema you know master of
world cinema so
yeah it was a great privilege to play a
part like that as an irishman and then
also as an actor to work with ken lodge
he was all shot around you know cork
where i'm from
in the summer time it was and it was a
beautiful summer it's beautifully
composed shots just of the landscape and
these these men
in the landscape and uh and all of the
stories in the script are based on real
life events and real-life characters but
they're kind of amalgamations
of those events and characters can you
tell me father
how there can be a fair election in this
country when the most powerful country
in the world threatens war
this is not the will of the people it is
the fear of the people how dare you talk
to me in the house of god silence
damn you though donovan you are a
disgrace to the memory of your parents
yes get out i don't think it had been
really dealt with
the war of independence in the civil war
uh cinematically
like that generations of families in
ireland went to see that
film
and i am very very very proud of it and
sort of
the message of the film
dunkirk
chris called me up and he said he was
making this film and uh
that it was about dunkirk
and then he sent me the script the
character doesn't have a name the
character is called shivering soldier
but i think that
um
what the character represents
is all of those men that came back
from that conflict you know
mentally destroyed
so i felt a great sort of sense of
responsibility to portray
the character
sensitively
and uh i did a lot of reading about it
i've played sort of characters with ptsd
a couple of times so i'm sort of
familiar with it
but all the veterans that went to see
that film
er thought the whole film was very very
truthful and very representative of what
sort of
happened you know
do you want to come below
it's much warmer
set up to win even
even big george
you feel safer on deck
you would too if you've been bombed you
both
it wasn't warm it wasn't warm but uh you
know i loved in that stuff that stuff is
great
uh and again like the the hull of the
ship that i've they they find me on that
actually built all of that so and it was
it was like these
breakers coming over it and uh you're
stood there i think i was on a wire or
something but you're in the middle of
the ocean sit on this thing and it's
very very real and then you have to dive
off and swim to the boat and
that's the way chris gets you to that
place because you're
experiencing it so therefore
you know that does a lot of the work for
you in terms of the performance and it
was yeah it was just a pleasure to work
you know with uh like barry kilgan and
mark rylance and that that level of
of actor again on on chris's films
speaking
i think everyone that read it at the
beginning knew that it was a different
level of
television script writing
but none of us could have predicted that
it
it would connect with people in such a
sort of strong way
and that like the fans are really really
really loyal and and we're all really
really proud i mean steve knight is a
phenomenal writer
and i think he you know he's just
he said to me once that writing the
scripts for peaky blinders it's like it
comes out of him like spring water do
you know what i mean because he's from
birmingham these are stories that he was
told as a kid so
uh this it comes from a place of truth
for him at the same time it's a highly
um
it's highly stylized and heightened
you know the the whole sort of look of
the show
costumes and the haircut and the caps
and there and the music it's it's it's
had a life of its own and people
identify with it you know it's delicate
mr shelby
concerns the factory down the road it's
bsa
rumors get started
rumors that there was a robbery
no believe what speak i asked
with petrol engines
so that's why they said from belfast
maybe maybe not
thomas
you're a bookmaker a robber a fighting
man you're not a fool
you sell those things to anyone you will
have part of the reason the show has
been successful is that it's
it was a world that hadn't been explored
before you know in america
sort of the the gangster genre or the
sort of story of you know immigrants
i.e cowboys
you know or
you know the italians in in scorsese you
know like that's been explored and
mythologized so effectively
over deck for decades whereas in britain
speaking as an irish man in britain like
that hasn't been explored so much
and then that world that industrial
world of birmingham it was the sort of
center
of manufacturing it was in in in britain
and in europe at the time
so yeah it was like and the sound design
of it
is very important as well as just heavy
industry happening
everywhere you know
and those furnaces would have been going
off like that everywhere so but also
it's visually
really appealing
[Music]
he has this uh very funny relationship
with
mortality
tommy
and because i think the stuff that he
witnessed
in france in the trenches
you know would changed him
and there are things that neither you or
i could ever imagine
and
uh
it was the worst job in the in the army
at that time being they called them clay
kickers
it was the worst job they would you know
they would they would tunnel down in
these in these um tunnels the size of
their body
and uh they would pass the earth back
and they would obviously the tunnels
would collapse
very often and then they would sometimes
they'd be tunneling parallel to the
to the germans you know and they would
and they would break through and have
these fights and there was like
hand-to-hand combat and
so to come out of that like tommy comes
out of that and has decorated and
saved lives and done all those things so
you can see why other
veterans of the war would have respect
for him
i think what makes him such a dangerous
adversary is that he is unafraid
to die and i think ultimately death to
him might seem like some sort of release
at some point in the near future mr
churchill will want to speak to you in
person mr shelby
he has a job for you
we will be in touch
get out of the grave tinker
be on your [ __ ] way
people bring that scene up a lot as
their favorite scene of the show
it's a brilliantly brilliantly uh
written scene brilliantly shot scene
and i remember reading it and going i
don't well that's it
he's dead i mean how is he going to get
out of this he's he's he's clearly dead
and no one predicts this sort of twist
in it
who hasn't seen it before and they and
uh
yeah we really spent a lot of time
making that
and shooting it and
and i think because
he's so close to death
that he almost welcomes it and then when
he survives it's like
[ __ ]
i have to keep going
i have to keep going
and it was a turning point in his his
development as a character i think i've
played him now for
five
this will be the fifth series so it's a
um
like i said about reprising characters
i've never done that before but i have
these roles that are extraordinarily
written in such great detail
and to be able to to go back to them
season after scene it's been a real gift
for me
and i suppose yeah it also it's very
personal because people can consume it
however they choose you know and blocks
in seasons in episodes
and you're beamed into their
living room so i feel like they have
some sort of kinship or
ownership or whatever that is stronger
than
a two-hour performance in a film
you know which eventually
it goes out of circulation films
naturally do whereas television
people will discover it and re-watch it
and keep re-watching it and it uh and it
develops this life of its own which is
unpredictable you know
breakfast on pluto
well i was in love with the book
which is written by pat mccabe
i had heard that neil jordan was making
the film
i was going to make the film i was aware
that there was a script so i
sort of pestered him for an audition
and i did a screen test where i kind of
glammed up and
you know
put on makeup and
and he liked the screen test and and and
we um
and eventually gave me the part and we
shot the movie and again as a character
i have deep deep affection for you know
because
the character just wants to look pretty
and
find her mom you know
i was born in a small town near the
irish border
i was left in a basket on a certain
doorstep
you know her once your real mother
[Music]
not many people can take the tale of
patrick kitten brady kitten
after seeing kitten you'll not bring my
retreat into this review
[Music]
it was a great exploration for me you
know i mean i had a book
as one resource i had the script as
another resource
and i wanted the character to be
feminine as opposed to effeminate
i think there's a difference
it was a very kind of delicate process
it took a long time to get to that
sort of physically to that
place and also sort of psychologically
to that place
um
but i had a great time making it you
know
it was a cast of the the sort of who's
who of irish film you know and
liam neeson and brenda gleason and
stephen rayne
they're
you know actors that i
have admired for years and uh it was
again a very formative experience for me
because it's a big big part and
a big challenge and i i had a i had a
great time
sunshine
well i've been look really lucky to
recollaborate with certain directors
over the over the course of my career
and um
so so this was also scripted by alex
garland and
it was danny's next film after 28 days
later and uh and
like i'd never done a sci-fi thing like
that danny had never done a sci-fi thing
like that and it was again trying to
make a film that was
a blockbuster but that was a kind of
um that was ticking all the boxes of a
blockbuster but that was actually
looking at themes a little bit more
sophisticated or a little bit more
challenging i suppose thematically than
your
conventional sci-fi blockbuster
our sun is dying
[Music]
mankind faces extinction
earth frozen in a solar winter
it was very very very technical and it
took a long time all of those technical
bits particularly the sequence where
we're like fixing the shield where we're
outside
89 of shield in full sunlight
[Music]
[Music]
go back
i'll finish this
please i can do this
there's a lot of wire work and in those
suits and things danny's so visually
sort of uh strong in all of his films
and we built this huge set
and uh they had this massive wall of
lights moving towards me and wind
machines and all that and i suppose in
in the film it's like
the character's communion with the sun
you know
and where it moves into a kind of a
transcendental kind of thing or whatever
[Music]
that that sequence was was great and
also just trying to get into that
headspace
was a great challenge for me you know
scientists are really
we should listen to scientists question
everything you know and that's what
those guys do who are kind of
like really
on the sort of
i don't know on the edge of knowledge
but i really really enjoyed it again
because it was
you know a clever
and challenging
uh mainstream film which is kind of
films that i'm
attracted to i suppose
[Music]
you